some reason okay
we're good it's all done okay so beth
did put in the um
chat if you wanted to have uh captions
that you could click that link
and um you would have that
so welcome everybody this is day two
of our three-part uh series on
research and farm labor and today
we are going to be talking about well
i'm not going to be but my colleagues
beth holtzman and john hendrickson are
going to be talking about
the farm labor dashboard and giving you
um
a little bit of a behind-the-scenes peek
at what we've got
there and this is a tool that is
designed
for farmers but also for technical
assistance providers in working with
farmers
and when we finish up we will have time
for questions but
i believe seth and i will be monitoring
the chat
as well so if you have questions during
the presentation
feel free to drop them in there and as
time allows we'll go ahead and get those
answered for you
so let's see beth i can't advance the
slide so i don't know if i'm done now or
not
okay there we go there's our there's our
faces this is only part of the
team we have aaron who is on board here
today we have kathleen liang who is on
board today and we have
uh jason parker who was up yesterday and
maybe
taking a break today so this is our team
that is our website any one of us are
happy to respond to
questions phone calls emails whatever
we are passionate about farm labor and
have spent
a few years working on this issue so
all right beth i will i guess i'm
turning it over to you right
yep um okay so today's session as mary
said
is going to focus on the tools and
resources
available at the farm labor dashboard
i'm going to start with a little bit of
background
then i'm going to give a quick tour of
the dashboard it's going to be pretty
speedy
and that includes a look at what's in
the resource library
we'll have some time for question and
answers
and hopefully some discussion at the end
um and i'm just going to prompt you now
that um
at the end please feel free to um
to turn on your mic and maybe your video
to ask your questions you can do it
through the
chat um if you want but if you have the
bandwidth and the interest we'd love to
hear your voices and see your faces
as well um so i just want to
start out and now i am going to ask you
to share share in the chat box
um with um why focus on labor
um could you if you could just tell us
what issues challenges or opportunities
you're seeing
um from whatever part of the country and
whatever um job or um
perspective you have we'd love to hear
that
so um don't be shy type in a sentence
yeah don't be shy um
and i guess i could even um to get us up
so
labor issues can end their farm oh i'm
sorry mary
don't you think it's a happy place to
start yeah
it can they're they're they're big for
sure
anybody else want to chime in
we have 32 people i bet mary or rubin if
we get 15
people to chime in so 14 more folks
and mary owes me a sandwich let's do it
people we can do this
somebody say it's expensive
yes it is they purchase my business
expense both farm and construction
business so yeah all right so now we
have 13 more to go
and i won't be hungry to improve
conditions for farm workers
excellent and compassionate
increased productivity nice
it's time consuming to have a continuous
turnover
yes and expensive as mary said
hard to find farm labor
uh big uh focus on reducing absenteeism
how
might we be able to do that
to keep young people in iowa or bring
families to our small towns
repopulate rural america yes
all good i'm going to um move on we
don't have 15 people yet then i owe
marry a reuben
labor is necessary to operate the farm
you keep counting i'm going to all right
you move on
so here was our team's assessment as we
came together from our various
um organizations and um institutions we
were seeing that
um that that like you all
noticed or brought out that it's a
significant expense
that for diversified and produce farms
labor costs range between
we were finding at the time between 35
and 60 percent of gross sales per acre
and when you're looking at small and
medium-sized farms
tight profit margins um having
uh good labor management is really key
to
viability and resilience we were finding
that it um
impacts farm scale and farmer roles and
also
farmers satisfaction with their quality
of life and
their business performance um
as people mentioned here scarce lubrical
and the seasonal nature of the work can
make it really hard to find
and keep employees and that redundancy
around training can be really
tiring for farmers a whole bunch of
regulatory challenges
um uh going back about five years
four or five years ago we were seeing
the labor department
um coming in and people finding
themselves owing some back wages
um and also a lot of policy uncertainty
associated with things like immigration
and administration of programs like h2a
and perhaps the biggest and most
important reason that
we all came together was that farmers
were telling us that they
need to boost their labor management
skills um
and knowledge and confidence
um so um the group of people that
mary mentioned earlier all came together
we've worked together on two multi-state
integrated research and extension
projects
um and so the research goals
are around increasing um
understanding in a variety of
topic areas and the extension goals are
to develop and share
new training education and resource
education resources
to help farmers become more effective
labor management managers
and in both um projects basically had
the same series of
activities we did a bunch of interviews
and focus groups and serve and some
survey work with farmers
there was data analysis looking at
themes
and gaps and then all that combined
in the development of tools and
information products
um here's just a quick um showing you
the different
organizations that have been involved um
so as jason discussed in his
presentation yesterday
the research phase of the project looked
at how farmers identify issues in labor
management and
he and kayla grouped these topics into
six major themes which you can see here
um
and they all are are part of the puzzle
of having good employees getting the
work done
in a timely way and for each of those
six
six themes there's actually um many more
different topics
and issues there's a lot going on i'm
not going to get into the details of
this but as
i bet all of you know it's both
complicated
and complex um
and that's the com the context for
how we were thinking about the tools and
resources we wanted to put together
in this online resource which we're
calling the farm labor dashboard
so right now what we have is a suite of
four interactive tools
we have a resource library more tools
and resources
are coming in the next phase of the
project which runs through
2022 and obviously
it's online and available 24 7
where farmers and people work with them
can access the resources
our content focus has really been on
helping farmers
build um skills knowledge
and confidence um to be better managers
to help them adopt effective protocols
and procedures
and to address barriers that they
encounter
we see that it has as mary mentioned
before multiple uses the farmers can
access the tools anytime for those of
you who are
educators you might be interested in
incorporating them in your education or
outreach programs
and business advisors who work
one-on-one
with farm businesses or a farm team
i think also might find some of these
resources helpful
in moving your clients forward with
their labor management
so um i'm gonna take you on a quick tour
through each of the tools
um so the first one is called the labor
readiness self-assessment
and um basically it focuses on six areas
planning
recruiting and hiring training and
supervision
recording record keeping record-keeping
taxes and insurance
performance reviews and ending
employment
and the tool provides a summary of
farmers strengths it identifies weak
links and it suggests resources that
will help them
address those areas of vulnerability
moving forward so it
is divided into 21 questions
um and in the six critical areas
um here are some examples of questions
um
that that people will be asked to answer
and they kind of have the same structure
and all of the questions are required so
you can
kind of look at those and based on how
people answer those questions they get a
visual
representation of their relative
strengths
and areas where they can build knowledge
and skill
and in any area where there's a weakness
they would get get some recommendations
for resources
to build um to move forward and
we tried very hard in our
recommendations
both to go from kind of a asset based
both you know really recognizing their
strengths that they can build
on and the positive benefits
of improving in the areas that might be
seen as weak links
so here's one example we have considered
the ways that hiring
employees will change our roles on the
farm
so if there
doesn't show what they selected but for
example if they answered no
we need more information or just
starting they'll get some
recommendations for where to go
um and for this particular question the
recommendation talks about how learning
to be an effective manager
typically requires a mental shift in how
we see ourselves
it recognizes where many farmers are
coming from that they got into farming
because they like the work of farming
but also brings their attention to the
challenges
and changes in the roles and activities
that will be necessary to be an
effective farm employer
things like they'll be likely to be
spending more time managing the work of
others
teaching and help others to be
productive and their own time is going
to shift to
doing hiring training record-keeping and
managing
so it's optimistic
focuses on learning to enjoy new roles
and and it sends people to specific
resources
so with that i'm going to shift over and
let um
john lead you through the employee cost
estimator
um as he was the major developer of this
tool
here john i think you're on mute john
thanks mary now we can hear you
so this is john hendrickson i'm at the
center for integrated
agricultural systems at the university
of wisconsin
um so one of the big
unknowns for a lot of especially
first-time
employers who are considering hiring
their first
uh first person to help them on their
farm is what exactly
is this going to cost and you know the
first thing for
a new employer to learn is that it's not
just the hourly wage
um i guess this is assuming that they're
going to be
paying the uh hiring above board and not
just paying somebody cash under the
table
so we built this employee cost estimator
to help people
understand the full cost of becoming an
employer and hiring people
on their farm so there
uh mary or uh beth you've got control of
the slide so you can advance for me
go ahead
so there is a tutorial video on the
website that walks people through the
tool
and in perhaps greater detail than i
will do here today
uh it is also uh true that there is both
this online version of the tool that i'm
going to be showing you here
as well as an excel version of it that
you can download
from from the website as well
okay
so it's not just wages in terms of the
full cost
you've got payroll taxes you've got
insurance workers compensation insurance
perhaps you're going to be
having to buy you know some farms have
specific tools that are you know these
are your tools
bob or sally and those are yours so you
might be having to buy some additional
things for your employees
might be having providing food or
providing housing
for employees you might be offering some
bonuses or
incentives
and there you've got the total cost so
what is that total cost so
this form is designed to walk people
through that process to get to that
total cost
okay so this is what the estimator looks
like online
uh the first step is to name the report
if you want to save it
and then you can plug in a job title for
an employee position that you're wanting
to hire
and then below that is a place to put
the hours by month for the different
positions that you might be hiring
and then there is a second tab there so
go ahead
beth the second tab in that section
after you do the hours is wages and
benefits and this is where you start
with the hourly rate
and then add in all those other items
that you might be
providing whether it's housing or food
or
retirement plan perhaps health
or other personal insurance bonuses and
gifts
and a person can use those categories
for you know for
even things that maybe are different
than the titles there as long as they
get all the costs and
then below that go ahead beth is
first there's a spot to you can do
multiple employees at the same time so
that you see a little button there at
the very top
that says add another employee so you
could add in a whole bunch of employees
and do them all at once
with different hours and different wages
and different benefits
and then at the bottom is where you
build in the other costs
federal unemployment tax
workers compensation state unemployment
tax
all um social security uh medicare all
those things
now some of these on the federal level
are standardized across states
some of them are obviously unique to
states and so this is a place where
a person using this tool very well may
have to do some addition some homework
on their end
in particular in terms of workers
compensation workers compensation
programs
vary widely from state to state in terms
of who is required
to enroll in workers compensation and
the specifics
of how those costs are structured and it
can be quite challenging to figure that
out on your own
we encourage people in the video
tutorial to contact
people like us service providers who
work with farmers to answer questions
or perhaps even better to contact other
farmers who are already employers
to find out what are what is a
what is a percentage to put in for
workers compensation in my state
you click submit um and one thing i will
note
while we're uh transitioning slides is
that
none of the data that farmers are
entering into this
site whether it's the excel spreadsheet
that they download or this online tool
is being collected or analyzed by anyone
it just
the form gets filled out you can
download and print the forms as pdfs or
save them on your computer
but they're not being saved on our end
so this is an example where a person put
in
uh one field crew person that was
working
1280 hours on the farm at a hourly pay
rate of 10
and so their you know base wages is 12
800 but then you build in uh the
benefits that were being offered they're
going to be providing some food
um and a bonus or a gift
and then building in the fico fuda
workers compensation in suda adds in all
those numbers
and so you have the total cost for the
employee for the year
and then what i think is an extremely
useful number for farmers
is the labor cost per hour this is
important
if you're sending crews out to do work
for you
it's kind of nice to know what the fully
loaded
labor cost per hour that you're paying
for that crew to do that person to do
when you're sending them out to do a job
so we call it an estimator because it
may may or may not
um be completely accurate depending on
how well
you've done your homework in terms of
some of that those factors like workers
compensation
um but it does provide a way
for uh particularly a new employer to
get a sense of what the full costs are
going to be for them
great thanks john
so the third tool that is on the
dashboard
is this job description generator
um and basically it helps people
um both sort of professionalize and
formalize
um and um provide consistency
in terms of creating job descriptions
for
the various positions on their farms
and there's six basic steps so
the step one is that you describe this
is what it looks like when you go there
you describe the over the positions
overall
role in the farm business um
and so you'll see that there's some
sample language there
that helps people get started for
describing their farm
and then the next step is to summarize
the major responsibilities
[Music]
and um it's possible to go ahead um and
do some of the
you know some people work from the big
picture and then fill in the details and
some people
um like to have all the details and from
that come up with their
their big picture so for some people it
might make sense to
um skip ahead to the next couple of sec
sections
and then go back and complete the
summary of the position you can see i've
highlighted there
um so right now the job description
generator is really focused on produce
farms
and it has um a pretty extensive list of
different kinds of tasks that
you can choose um for what what
the tasks are that are associated with
that position
and the approximate percentage of the
total work time
um and in this slide you can see
that any place that it had that little
plus
it can open up and there are a whole
bunch of sub um
sub categories of tasks that you can
select from
to create your job description
the next step is to think through
the qualifications and skills and
experience that are required for that
position
and to list the wages and benefits as
well as who the person will report to
categorize the type of position
and hit submit and when you hit submit
um you kind of get a written you get a
job description
you can download it both as a pdf
to use as is or as a word document so
you could further edit and modify it
um so um so either way works and again
like the job
like the estimator it doesn't store work
so you need to to create a new version
you would have to
start over
our fourth tool is a policy manual
generator it's a lot like the job
description generator
and it provides sample language um to
help build a policy manual which um uh
you know is considered an uh an
important part
of um of of having a
well-run farm letting your employees
know
what's expected of them um and
having everybody be treated the same and
fairly
um and um there's a big caveat here
about making sure that you
check with your state labor department
or your own attorney to make sure
that the policy manual is in compliance
with
um your state's laws and best practices
um
so the policy manual generator is
divided into 12 topic areas
and each topic area has several items
and in each one there's some sample
language
that um to get you started um
so it gives people an idea of of
what what to put into those um slots
because we found that you know just
starting with a blank
piece of paper or word document could be
a pretty overwhelming
place to start for someone in developing
their farm policy manual
and you can see that there's places
there's either xxx
or a blank which indicates places where
the user needs to fill in the specifics
for their farm
and again you need to download and print
your work and again you get a pdf
version
or a word version that you can further
edit
and the final component of the dashboard
is this
resource library which is searchable
using we have this filtering factor so
you can
search according to topic the material
type and the location
to look for resources that are pertinent
to what you're working on
so if for example you chose from the
topic of managing employees there's
multiple subtopics you could choose
supervision and then you could decide
what
what material um kinds of material
there's videos there's fact sheets
there's some audio
there's um i think maybe whole
curriculum
so you can choose what you're interested
in looking at and then the location is
basically the four usda regions so that
would be
northeast north central
south and west
so the kinds of materials we have
there's um we've we're also pointing to
existing resources that are available at
other online libraries
um including the agricultural risk
management library
and the beginning farmer and rancher
development program um library which is
called farmanswers.org
and as i just said because because we
recognize that different people learn in
different ways some things are covered
in multiple ways so there might be a
fact sheet and a short video tutorial
that essentially cover the same topics
but we can imagine some people would
prefer to download it and read it
away from their screen other people
would be much more apt to
watch a video there's video
we have some templates of things like
job um
applications that people can use
download put your logo in
um checklist for a new employee
orientation
we also work to fill in some gaps so
here's an example of some
simple fact sheets we developed to help
farmers make job interviews more
meaningful
more professional and more consistent so
those are easily
downloadable and if you were
using the readiness assessment and your
answers there indicated that you didn't
have a lot of experience
or a formal process for hiring process
they would refer you to these resources
as things you could use
to get you started
so um there are also resources
related to legal aspects of labor
management most of which were developed
by our colleagues at
farm commons and here's a couple of
examples
um and just to like wrap up
tips on using the dashboard tools
um so you know if it's your first time
use the instructional information
provided with each tool
regardless of whether you're reading or
watching the video
take advantage of the sample language
be sure to download your work this one's
really important
and let us know what else is needed and
would be helpful
suggestions for your for for
farmer-ready resources are really
quite welcome
in uh the next phase of our work we're
going to be
continuing to look at the way that
labor and mechanization
decisions influence
and have impacts on investments in labor
equipment and machinery
and to integrate what we're finding into
education and resource materials
we're going to be continuing to analyze
skill sets farmers need
from workers and farm characteristics
farmer workers look for and again
integrate all that into our education
and resource materials
thanks to funding we just found out
about earlier this month
we're going to be able to offer a whole
new round of farmer
education later this year and in 2022
which
will um use many of these resources
and um to to help the education is going
to
primarily be offered online both in
online and self-study opportunities
and we're going to continue to develop
and test
tools at the dashboard
so one example is to have a tool similar
to the employee cost estimator to look
at the
interrelationships of mechanization and
the amount of kind
and kind of labor that's needed in an
operation
and that is the end of our presentation
so
um like to open it up to questions first
um and if we have time then we can move
to i think we will to
some more broad-based discussion
so far no questions a lot of compliments
about the tools
can we register to get updates and
taking advantage of future phases
is a question natalie asks absolutely
um so i have your contact information
now we have it now and we will
definitely use that to continue to
let people know what's what's coming
what's available i'll throw in that if
you use any tools and you have some
great successes or ways you've used them
and you could share those anecdotes with
us
that would be helpful to us as well
including on suggestions for improving
one thing that um john had this great
idea when he was looking at his um cost
calculator tool
in conversations with your employees in
any of their reviews or whatnot
potentially using that information to
share
hey here is the cost um you know and
here's here's what your hourly wages
given your
you know promo csa share vacation
whatever have you and
john i won't share any further because
you are here but i don't know if you
want to expand on that in any way
yeah the notion was that you know one
thing that
can be a struggle
for any employer is motivating their
employees to
be you know productive and effective
uh and contributing to the farm and
you know you as as the farm owner you
know you're you're
living and breathing and you get it how
important it is to
to work and get the jobs done
effectively and in a timely manner and
it could be more difficult for them you
know an employee
to to see that so we thought that you
know one way that a farmer could use
that
that information from the cost
estimators to share that with their
employees that you know i'm
yeah i'm paying you 12 dollars an hour
but you're actually costing me 16
an hour and so it can
maybe help impress upon that employee
the need for them to be uh productive
uh when they're on the farm is that what
you're getting at seth
yeah exactly so um somebody asked if we
could put the dashboard
website on the ad in the chat and so i
just did um
so you could click on that and get to
that thank you john
mary tossed about offering a disk
workplace profile as part of our
building effective teams
that is just simply fabulous and mary is
a great instructor
what additional tools are we considering
team oh back to john
well i just uh would think it would be
nice
for for mary to perhaps briefly exp
for those of us who don't for those in
our audience who don't know
what the acronym disc is why don't you
briefly tell people well done john
well um so there it's not really an
acronym in that it doesn't actually
stand well it does stand for something
but
um it basically is a workplace profile
it's a profile tool in the same way that
myers breaks you might have taken
myers-briggs or you might have taken
colors or you know there's any kind of
different kind of
personality assessments that are out
there this one
zeroes in there's a couple reasons why
we like it it zeros
in on this one specifically on the
workplace environment and it helps to
help you helps you better understand
basically what are the things that
motivate you
and what are the things that stress you
out and
what kinds of people are your sort of
natural allies in the workplace and what
kinds of people might you have to step
out of your comfort zone to work with
and
you know as managers we have to do that
all the time
and i have done this now with hundreds
of farmers
and it's incredibly accurate they always
love doing it
and it's just it's not it's not all you
have to do
it's necessary but it's not sufficient
but anyway so the offer i made is that
if you're if you're a farmer and you
want to know about
uh when we'll be offering it next then
drop your email in the chat
and we'll stay in touch um if you are a
technical assistance provider or an
extension agent and you work with
farmers
and you'd like to partner with us on
offering it then
let me know that as well and we're happy
to do that so
um it's it's a fun little piece i don't
recommend that we do it during the
height of the season but it's
it's a really nice sort of preparation
tool going into the training season so
so there's that and um beth did you tell
them about the tailgate trainings
i didn't why don't you why don't you
share about that okay
we uh one of the fun well i i will say
fun and quotations mark because i might
be the only one that actually thinks is
this fun
on the team but um one of the things
that we'll be adding under resources
is a series of sort of tailgate
trainings
and what those will be
is very short training segments that
farmer managers can download and use
in their own professional development to
get better or
with their directly with their employees
so you know if you're a farmer
you've got a staff meeting every tuesday
at 10 o'clock and you know you get some
coffee and you hang out
then it's like this would be a really
cool way
to give you some thoughtful ideas on how
you might structure
a staff training or some topics that you
might want to discuss with your staff
so and i see we have a disc fan in the
audience also indeed
um we also have um what is a job
satisfaction questionnaire for ag
workers
um which is which is in the works so
that would be excellent
if you interface with mary or beth and
they could send it all out to everyone
when you're done with that that sounds
great
so if you have ideas for training topics
if you have ideas
if you have really cool tools out there
as seth said if you there are places
that you use
let us know what they are send us the
links um we're not we would love to
house those links on the dashboard with
permission and
proper credit of course but um
you know we just we want to make this as
useful to farmers as we can possibly
make it
hopefully down the road we'll be able to
branch out and look at
livestock based farms as well but that's
kind of a different animal so
so to speak so to speak
animal friendly as well and so malcolm
sent us
uh the questionnaire that they're
refining so that's excellent
to beth our techie person for that
so yeah so all the tools will be
integrated into the
education that we'll be offering in the
um later
this year and in 2022
um so we'll be providing support for
farmers to
um to learn about um
to learn and to implement changes on
their farms we also have a curriculum
related to negotiation which
will be incorporated which can be really
helpful
um in the employment and management
sphere of their work
so any other questions
not many so far
this is the part of the part of the
session
where um i was hoping maybe some of you
might um
unmute and maybe turn on your video
and um and share or
comment
you may have to throw the reuben up
again seth
we can do ah kristen yay
i'm showing my video but i have no i
have no particular comments to make
can you make one up you know you're here
you made eye contact
about anything i am i'm interested in
the
satisfaction questionnaire so thank you
malcolm for for sharing that
springfield community garden you're on
mute if you
want to unmute if you have something you
want i can mention just
um which a couple of you are aware of
but we've developed an
a guide to writing a farm and play
manual for massachusetts farms with a
lot of guidance on the massachusetts
specific laws on that front so that um
we're actually
just putting finishing touches on the
web version of that we've had it in
hardcopy form for a while so that'll be
on our
website bylocalfood.org
in the coming week hopefully or two
weeks at the most
so that's the one resource i have to
offer
great thanks
yeah i would also say that the um the
legal guides as you might imagine
are state specific that are on our site
so
uh you'll see some for vermont new
hampshire
pennsylvania uh wisconsin north carolina
i mean
so and the farm commons also has a lot
of
resources on their site for other states
as well so
always a great a great place to go
hi mary this is miley springfield
community gardens hello
hi miley hi i took your disc
training about a year ago and i really
enjoyed it
and we would love to talk with you more
about doing that for our staff
we have a four farm incubators and seven
full-time farmers
and then um you know just 18 community
gardens and we'd just love to learn some
more
about how we can be more effective
managers awesome i'll be in touch
thank you okay
yeah i do i love doing disc trainings um
as does seth but seth i'm not going to
volunteer seth because he's
um he has a full plate right now
thank you mary there are a lot of fun
though i agree kristen can you put into
the website in the chat
um i googled but could not get the
website
yes i will do that and i'll actually put
the link to the
the future employee manual where it will
be landing in a
another week or so but yeah you've got
it looks like angela put our our website
up there thanks angela
and you know beyond just the scope of
this
um if you have resources that you come
across that you think are really good or
would be good models for us
again we would love to know i mean it's
um
as beth said this labor stuff is
uh complex and complicated and
um it's not going to get better any time
soon i don't think
but it's um it's a nut that we all have
to crack
so um we would love
we are hoping that we will be able to
start some sort of a learning network or
a community of practice or something
around these kinds of issues and
so that maybe we don't have to reinvent
all the wheels
every time
so angela's link brings us to your um
home page
do you want to get us i guess it would
resource farmers that's where
you i would find it
a learning network would be appreciated
that would be actually an interesting
idea mary
yeah i'm going to put my email in the
chat now so
that people can reach out to me if they
why don't you just put your home phone
number in there and they can just call
you at home
well oddly enough seth my home phone
number is now in my email soon
boundaries have completely eluded me
so come on over for dinner whatever so
all right well i'm not seeing a lot of
other questions or comments but again
as you think of these things if you um
did send me a message and ask for more
information i will be in touch
um and
other than that i think
whoops
cultivating success through wsu is that
wisconsin extension or
washington state university yeah that's
obviously it
i shared this course with them last
night as labor was a subject we were
covering
i hope other is in the course were able
to join so thank you candace
you could share that dashboard too if
you wanted
and kristen put a more precise link in
the guy
in the chat employee manuals
a generator for massachusetts farms
christian anything that says groovy is
our generator
she's gone i'll let you judge as soon as
it as soon as it goes live
well done so
um just to um let everybody know um
we'll be we're recording this and um
well as soon as we can we'll be posting
the recording
and also the slides and um
some you know links like the links to
the
buy local food website and new guide
um the things that have come up will be
posting all that and then i'll be
sending that out to everyone who
pre-registered
so that you'll have access to it
yeah so previews of coming attractions
we wrap up this series tomorrow
tomorrow we've got kathleen liang will
be
presenting on her experience she's a
member of our team and she's working in
north carolina and she'll be talk
sharing some of
her experience in research that she's
collected
and then we'll also be hearing from
rachel
armstrong and jennifer hashley on a
stair project that they've been working
on for a couple years now
on um
labor pools is the best way i can
describe it without getting
too too detailed and two in the weeds
but um so if you're interested in those
please come back and join us again
tomorrow
we will also be recording it we we hope
fingers always crossed on that
and then these will all become part of
the resources
in the dashboard site
not much more in the chat thanks and yes
others from washington state did attend
i think you answered natalie's question
hey and i am trying to get back to
everybody who's sending me private
messages about
disc thank you for keeping me busy um
drop your email in the chat so that
it'll be easy it'll be a little easier
for me to pull out
and get back to you
and i think that's it
yeah i think we can wrap up we can give
you 12 minutes
fabulous thank you thank
you're you john that's 12 minutes at no
extra charge